si ces trois jeunes ukrainiens ont
choisi terre-neuve-et-labrador comme
refuge pour fuir la guerre c'est d'abord
à cause du nom de la province
mais depuis leur arrivée ce sont plutôt
les mots terre-neuve qui prennent tout
leur sens
au delà de son nom invitant la province
a multiplié les efforts pour attirer des
réfugiés comme eux elle a été la
première analyse est elle-même un vol
est la seule à ouvrir un bureau
temporaire en pologne pour mieux guider
ceux qui ont fui l'ukraine green
et unique des need
et le gouvernement n'est pas seul à
vouloir faire sa part ce terre-neuvier a
créé un groupe facebook de soutien aux
réfugiés ukrainien qui compte
aujourd'hui plus de 17000 membres un
divan à donner des emplois disponibles
quelques dizaines d'offres ils sont
publiés chaque jour
une démonstration de l'hospitalité et de
la générosité qui font la force de la
province selon michael rogers
et ses démonstrations on les voit un peu
partout parlez-en à sergei qui poursuit
sa carrière de barbier loin de la guerre
et qui reçoit des pourboires de la part
de terre neuvien qui ne sont même pas
ses clients
l'histoire fait probablement partie du
90% avec son groupe de tricot elle a
amassé 1500 $ et un panier de cadeaux
pour une famille kényane
nous devons tous faire quelque chose
pour les aider explique-t-elle
sam est celle de l'aîné l'a aussi bien
compris elle à accélérer les travaux de
rénovation son appartement pour
accueillir ces trois jeunes locataires
craignait
il n'y a pas que les ukrainiens
terre-neuve-et-labrador veut attirer la
province qui à la population la plus
vieille sens du pays souhaite accueillir
5000 100 nouveaux arrivants par année
d'ici 2026 titi est
une solution qui s'impose pour le co
propriétaire de salon de barbier où les
candidats qualifiés comme sergei sont
rares et précieux
maicon espère quant à lui que son groupe
facebook ne sera bientôt plus destinée
qu aux ukrainiens mais plutôt à tous les
immigrants auprès d'eux pour
aux
cantonales
un souhait partagé par ceux qui ont pu
profiter de cette vague de soutien aux
hôpitaux et adria
need some time ce week end
et qui promettent déjà de redonner au
suivant ici mathieu papillon
radio-canada saint-jean terre-neuve